happy hour is not always so happy we
conducted a social experiment
a zoom happy hour for the whack pack
okay i want to know if they would get
along or would it lead to a lot of
fighting
so i had shirley set up a meeting mary
anne from brooklyn was the first one to
arrive
then sour shoes and then high pitch eric
hi
[Music]
hi eric hello
hi eric hi shower
eric do you remember the song we were
singing in the back of the velary
no in my house
in my house my house
[Music]
very nice yeah i mean what could go
wrong with people singing together how
sweet
yeah literally three minutes in and
nobody could hear me i can't get
anyone's attention
the wheels have fallen off next king of
all blacks came on
hey julie what's up do i have one too
much jewelry
look at you shining 15 000.
just for the watch or was that a break
for the watch 15
000.
yeah so then medicated pete came into
the happy hour right truly
and yes and king of all blacks
immediately started goofing on medicated
pete
pete you got to turn your phone sideways
yo he looks like he's the one
hey he look like he wanted in one of the
mirrors the fun mirrors
fun house man
he looked like a
yeah we all can't be dreamboats like
king of all black
tan mom was the last to arrive okay
and she had trouble turning on her video
and high register sean was her hero he
tried helping her
hey guys
patricia's on where's your video we
don't see you
i know i was telling someone no this is
terrible i had so much trouble getting
on and i don't know how to get
onto is she on zoom i don't see
her you see click click click
click click on your own i i can i can
hang
up or click click click on your own
image
and then when it says start stop still
not start
video click that wow yeah i could listen
to him give directions all day
not only could she not figure it out at
one point she
was on facetime and adam bartow was on
zoom
holding the face type up it was so
bananas and really all she probably had
to do is hit a button right i mean
howard we sent them all a link to their
all you gotta do is push the link it
brings you right into the room
that's it so things took a real turn
when king of all blacks tried to explain
how he was on
more of an upper level than everyone
else there hey i'm insulted even being
on here with these [ __ ]
we can't talk over each other what's up
king
i thought this zoom was gonna be out of
upper upper shot
king then called jeff the drunk a loser
oh by the way jeff was like 30 minutes
late to the [ __ ] pig
can we just say hello to mr jeff curo
who's checked in
jeff the trunk hey man another another
loser
what's up what's up loser what's up
loser
you should never lose again
how does it feel to be a loser on friday
night
look in the mirror and tell me i ain't
no loser
i ain't no loser [ __ ]
what an argument oh my god by then
everyone had enough of each other and
decided to say goodbye and once again
they all spoke at the same time so it's
just how
long did it last surely i know the
ending lasted
almost as long as the entire happy hour
yeah here's when everyone starts finally
getting annoyed
you guys stay safe all right goodbye
love you
guys thank you
thank you thank you truly
[Music]
all right medicated pete we know he
can't say goodbye to anyone on the phone
he has ocd
and his problem is he can't say goodbye
so sour shoes and medicated pete stayed
on after
everybody else had left said goodbye
they closed out the happy hour by
singing come sail away
[Music]
but i'll try
[Music]
is
i think this is what broke the camel's
back and truly moved to alabama